[موسيقى]
يعتبر الحل المرن للجوّال مهمًا جدًا في
الوقت الحالي لأن أحد
العوائق الرئيسية التي تحول دون التبني على نطاق واسع هو
شحن القلق ولا
توجد حلول شحن كافية
لا يمكن فعلاً مواكبة
[موسيقى]
الشحن الثابت اليوم الذي يقدمه الشاحن
المكان أمام الشاحن
ويقتصر على أن الزيجي يخدم جميع
المساحات في ساحة انتظار السيارات ، لذا فهو
يوفر حقًا مرونة كاملة للموقع
[موسيقى]
من المهم جدًا أن يكون لديك ميزة الحجز
لأن شخصًا ما يبحث اليوم
عن شاحن ربما يحصل عليه  هناك
يتم استخدام الشاحن ، وبهذه الطريقة
يعرفون أنه إلى أين يذهبون ، سيكون
لديهم شاحن جاهز لشحن سيارتهم
[موسيقى]
مدن في جميع أنحاء العالم
تضع حقًا تفويضات
تتطلب عددًا كبيرًا من أجهزة الشحن الإلكترونية ،
تم تصميم ziggy للسماح للمدن التي
تعمل مع المواقع بالقول إنها تبدأ
ببضعة وحدات متنقلة نظرًا لزيادة السعة بالإضافة
إلى الوحدات المتنقلة ولكن لا حاجة
لوضعها في  البنية التحتية المتطورة اليوم
والتي هي صعبة للغاية في كثير من
الحالات من المستحيل وضعها في
[الموسيقى]
لك